President Trump also facing massive
backlash after saying in an interview
that he would be open to hearing dirt on
his 2020 rivals from foreign governments
watch your campaign this time around if
foreigners if Russia if China if someone
else offers you information on opponent
should they accept it or should they
call the FBI I think maybe you do both I
think you might want to listen I don't
there's nothing wrong with listening if
somebody called from a country Norway we
have information on your opponent oh I
think I'd want to hear you want that
kind of interference in our elections
it's not an interference they have
information I think I'd take it if I
thought there was something wrong I'd go
maybe to the FBI if I thought there was
something wrong but when somebody comes
up with Apple research right they come
up with out my research oh let's call
the FBI the FBI doesn't have enough
agents to take care of it but you go and
talk honestly to congressmen they all do
it they always have and that's the way
it is it's called Oppo research
democratic 2020 Canada's were quick to
pounce as you can imagine Joe Biden
tweeting that it's a threat to our
national security Kamala Harris taking
it a step further saying the president
himself is a national security threat
Kirsten Gillibrand saying it's time for
Congress to begin impeachment hearings
and Elizabeth Warren echoing Gillibrand
also calling for impeachment House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi and Senate Minority
Leader Chuck Schumer
harshly criticizing the president the
president gave us once again evidence
that he does not know right from wrong
it's a very sad thing for the president
to be so Cavalier to disregard to be
indifferent to law and any sense of
ethics about who we are as a country to
say he would invite aren't an
intervention further the intelligence
community with great competence is put
forth that they're Russians interfere
interfered in our election that's an
assault on our democracy to say that it
is okay to interfere that we shouldn't
have any law enforcement that we should
have no knowledge is to encourage Russia
China North Korea Iran to interfere in
our elections with no recourse shame
Shayne Jesse I was gone one day get back
and we're still talking about Russia but
this is obviously getting a lot of
attention today this might be one of the
dumbest controversies in the Trump
administration and there's been a lot of
dumb controversies I think this might
even take the cake so little George goes
into the Oval and he starts trying to
create a scandal over a hypothetical so
George comes in and mr. president the
ambassador to China you know he says to
you that that Bernie stiffed a waitress
at Denny's what do you do well Trump
says I'd listen maybe I'd call the FBI
impeach I mean you have to be kidding me
Trump gets word that that Bernie's
stiffed the waitress he has to call the
FBI
it's there are thousand different
hypothetical scenarios that you could be
talking about what did the president say
listen maybe I'd call the FBI that's all
he said the left is freaking out over a
hypothetical but they're not looking at
the reality Hillary actually did this
Hillary paid a foreign agent to get
Russian dirt and then she used it to
wiretap President Trump or what about
warrants foreign interference how about
when all those foreign governments paid
millions of dollars to the Clinton
Foundation when she was running for
president our little Adam chef remember
he was on the phone call we have the
audio oh we have naked Trump he was all
ears he didn't call the FBI the whole
thing is so stupid and it goes back to
the Trump Tower meeting where Don Jr
thought he was gonna get dirt on Hillary
didn't get it they didn't have it no
money changed hands like they did with
the Clintons and the whole meeting was
set up by fusion GPS this is all
ridiculous well I tell you Jesse you
need a bigger show you're gonna have to
keep shoveling and try to get out of
this one let me just say this is so
ridiculous there is a United States law
this is not a matter of opposition
research there's a law that says you
cannot accept money or in-kind
contribution from a foreign government
let me finish this is this is a
president what Nancy Pelosi said cannot
tell right from wrong but legal from
tell me about the atashi how's it
different than the das is totally don't
positive this is where you could
infusion GPS as an American company
Russian enough of the shoveling let me
just pick the true bonnets facts
Christopher Rhea who is trumps FBI
director and said this is wrong what did
Crump say Christopher Rhea is wrong no
Christopher rate the FBI director is
right and by the way Jesse when you try
to blame and derive George
Stephanopoulos this was no gotcha moment
for this president
you essentially you're insulting the
president because the president knows
exactly what he's doing knows exactly
what he's saying this is no gotcha
moment you saw the sound I have no
answer on the dossier Russians read the
report using GPS was working with
Christopher Steele as an American you
guys what happened sentence so the
question is does this apply to everybody
does the standard apply so during the
2016 election apparently it was okay to
reach out with cash and money to pay
foreign actors to get opposition
research from foreign Russian
adversarial sources to then bring it to
the FBI but Nancy Pelosi today is saying
that if someone reaches out to you as a
Republican that is unethical that is a
criminal cover-up and that is not
allowed when it comes to the dossier
when the left was exposed as being
behind the funding for that the Clinton
can campaign in the DNC they claimed it
was just opposition opposition research
it doesn't matter that it came from a
foreign source or who the sources was we
were just doing our job as a campaign to
get information but when the president
uses the same argument from The Oval
Office saying he might call the FBI but
he's going to listen to the information
then all of the sudden they're calling
for more in Pietschmann on the basis
that he's a criminal
well there's a double standard here do
we want foreign interference in our
elections no there are reasons why we
have laws
foreign donations and foreign money
being used for campaigns but if we're
gonna talk about this there's gonna be a
whole lot of people in Washington DC
we're guilty of colluding or using
information from foreign governments
including Democrats to interfere in
elections and it's 512 go for it well
Democrats just don't talk to Norway okay
but yes I agree Jesse you're totally
dead on it is completely ridiculous this
story is ridiculous
it was a fabricated story because George
planted this you know what would you do
if this I wish the president said well
I'm glad I didn't contact the FBI last
time around because the guy was running
the FBI was working against me
right yes so that's one example when you
shouldn't call the FBI when the head of
the FBI is working for the other
campaign which is what happened yes
Papadopoulos contacted the FBI and said
all these foreign agents are trying to
spy on me and what did they do to him
let me just tell you you guys are
covering up for something that's
inexcusable remember when they plug this
information they have hooks in you and
you are not representing the best
interest of our country either you're
working for that foreign government
opportunity on a couple of things one I
would I've been so terrified of getting
in trouble that I would always call the
FBI because I do not ever want to get in
trouble and I know that if the rush of
trainees or their agents or just wish if
they call me with information I would
call but I also think the President
Trump could have say well what about the
Obama administration what were they
doing to prevent interference in our
election I'd love to hear that answer to
that George and flip it on him it also
is another good example of doing a
really important big interview to
broaden out your reach and the interview
even though they talked about the
economy a little bit something about
this is going to blow up so it's like if
you were the press secretary well like
jump on that grenade here we are once
again